What is your argument then? You say,
"I'm not a historian, but I'm going to
spend my time talking about history. I'm
not a journalist, but I'm going to spend
my time talking about this thing. I'm
not an expert on this, but I'm going to
spend my time talking about this thing."
It's a weird move. Yeah. No, you don't
think, "No, I'm a free American. I can
talk about what it would all be
different." Yeah. Is them for 60 years.
It would all be different, too.
The World Bank said in 1996 for the
World Bank. This doesn't mean anything.
This is a non-argument. Yes. I'm saying
the World Bank did their own analysis of
this and they said that was a 40%. Hold
on. You got to stop interrupting and let
him finish.
actually backfires on you. This is one
of the things many reaction videos I've
seen to this haven't caught on this.
I've caught on this slightly dog.
You're not an expert on Islam. You have
been perpetuating lies against Islam
over and over again. You're not an
expert. So, this backfire on you, you
clown. Eight months ago, I downloaded
Audible and I was going through the
books there and they only had the Sierra
and I was like, why isn't anyone doing
an Islamic version of Audible? And
finally true ilm has come up with an app
and sisters where it's an Islamic
version going through what Quran
scholarly gems da woman hadith s and
history and kids and check this out
check how this sounds upon him that a
man would set out from Yemen or mudah we
have got the Muslim audible brother and
sisters finally alhamdulillah to seek
true ilm they've only got a limited
amount of space for the beta mode
brothers and sisters download it now and
benefit from it cuz let me tell you
something it is going to change the
knowledge that I seek throughout my life
inshallah brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in so
we're going to be reacting to inshallah
Joe Rogan and Dave Smith absolutely
humiliating Douglas Murray but there are
two key points where Douglas Murray
actually shot himself in the foot
without actually realizing and it was
absolutely flipping hilarious to me so
let's start off inshallah with the first
clip in see how he gets slapped around
it delitually but if you throw a lot of
out there's some point at which and
just raising questions is not a valid
thing you're not raising questions
you're asking questions, you're telling
people something. Do you think Gary's
doing that? I think there's a whole
bunch of guys doing that. I think Dave
is doing that very obviously. Dave's a
comedian, but he's now mainly talking
about Israel. I don't know if I'm mainly
talking about Israel. That's what I see.
Yeah, but that's what you've seen. But
that is also your shtick now, isn't it?
Well, what do you mean by that's my
shtick? Well, you're not a geopolitics
guy in general, are you? I don't even
know exactly what you're asking. I'm
saying you've decided, being a comedian,
you've decided now to become somebody
who talks about Israel. I don't I think
you're incorrect. I don't think it's a
decision. I just think you have long
form conversations, multiple of them.
It's a huge event that's in the news, so
it comes up. I don't think it's a thing.
I think if you're on the outside, you'd
say, "Oh, look, they're trying to get
attention by talking about this very
polarizing issue publicly." But they do
you do get attention from that. If you'd
spent the last year speaking about
Myanmar, you would not be on my lips.
Yeah. But he does talk about Yemen
constantly. He talks about a lot of
things that aren't in the news. Well, I
tend to talk about the conflicts that my
government is directly involved in,
which I think is reasonable to me, but I
don't quite get like what's all the
appeal to authority stuff. I mean, you
have to be an expert or I think
authority matters. I think authority
matters. I think but if you just throw a
lot of out there and then say I'm
not interested in the alternative views
on this and particular it's a counter
narrative that is wildly off and when
you get people look I just feel we
should get out straight away I feel
you've opened the door to quite a lot of
people who've now got a big platform who
have been throwing out counterhistorical
stuff of a very dangerous so in a
nutshell guys he's having a go at Joe Ro
you have open the door to people like
Dave Smith and his lies to talk expert
on what does one need to be an expert to
be talking about there's a genocide
innocent men being killed they are
indiscrim targeting them. Sniper bullets
hitting children's heads, private parts.
What expert do you need to be? Does one
need to be expert in what? In what? He's
having a go at Joe Rogan for putting him
in there. And there's a
counternarrative. What's the counter
narrative that they you your the
government that you support by the
English? I don't even know what
connection you have that they are
massacring these people. Yes. And that's
the counter narrative. You want us to be
like, "Okay, yes, it's okay to kill men,
women, and children." or dynamics to all
of this is that we have, at least since
911, been in a state of perpetual war.
All of these wars have been disasters.
There have been so many lies involved in
selling all of them. The whole Iraq war,
the whole war in Afghanistan, just lying
the whole way through. It's just like
lie after lie after lie with disastrous
wars. And so, this does create a fertile
ground for people to say, I wonder if
they were lying about all these wars.
I'm not really trying to argue about I
think the interesting question is
whether you're busy watering it. Well,
should you not talk about mistakes that
were made overall? Absolutely. You
should. Absolutely. I'm all for going
back and looking at mistakes. So, what
are what is your argument then? You say,
"I'm not a historian, but I'm going to
spend my time talking about history. I'm
not a journalist, but I'm going to spend
my time talking about this thing. I'm
not an expert on this, but I'm going to
spend my time talking about this thing."
It's a weird move. Yeah. No, you don't
think, "No, I'm a free American. I can
talk
about this." You can, but the point is,
what are you pushing? What are you
watering? What am I pushing? Uh,
liberty, free markets, peace,
prosperity, not getting in another
stupid catastrophic war, which we're on
the precipice of right now. And you keep
weaving and Okay, in a nutshell, who's
been uh pushing these wars? Benjamin
Netanyahu, this scum dirt pack, Satan.
He is the one that has been pushing this
narrative and telling them to go to war
with this person and that person. Why?
Not for America's interest, for the
United States, of Israel's interest. And
that's why Americans are fed up and
they're waking up. It's the beginning of
the end of Israel. And he says, for
example, um what are you um it's it's
fertile ground and what are you
watering? In a nutshell, your objective
news, because this is what they say now,
objective news means now you're pro
Hamas. Pro Hamas. They're even going
after Miss Rachel for saying they'll
dehumanize Palestinian children. The
government made the woman cry and then I
saw an experiment in central London
about this hunting Hamas me down. You
can watch that. But let's carry on. A
tabs on China. Would you point out and
it was the Trump administration? I'm
saying you take it obviously very
personally and that's you're right to do
so. Of course. I'm just trying to make
sure we're accurate here. What do you
think I'm taking personally? The
American wars. Sure. Yeah. I think they
they've killed hundreds of thousands of
people and cost my country $8 trillion
and and degraded my country very much.
And there's a very good argument to make
on that. I'm still slightly beused about
this move from I'm an expert on this and
I have views to I'm a comedian. I've
never claimed to be an expert on
anything. This is the problem, Joe. I
mean, if if if somebody says, you have
to claim to be an expert on something to
have an opinion on something. You don't
have to be. You don't have to be. But
the I'm not a historian, but I'm pumping
out history. I'm not an expert, but I'm
talking all the time about this. But
you're not even talking about
specifically on what he just said. No,
I'm saying this is my point about this.
He You say I'm not an expert. So, what's
the solution? To not talk about it. No,
it's to have more experts around. Well,
the expert class hasn't done a great
job. This is follow the
science. I just said I agree with during
all of I will put my track record
against any of the expert class on CO.
I'm glad to do that. So, should I have
just shut up? Should I have shut up by
opposing lockdowns and opposing vaccine
mandates and talking about the argument?
That's the entire argument that you're
making. Let the experts handle this.
You're not an expert. I was just wildly
miss again as you can see clearly. So
he's basically saying nobody in any of
look God almighty has given us some kind
of morality to see for bad and good.
Okay. Of course you need experts in
specific fields but this actually
backfires on you. This is one of the
things many reaction videos I've seen to
this haven't touched upon. I've caught
on this. I've caught on this slightly is
that he's saying you have to be an
expert. Douglas Murray, you're not
an expert on Islam. You have been perpet
perpetuating lies uh against Islam over
and over again. You're not an expert. So
this backfire on you, you clown. You do
you don't know nothing about Islam.
You've been lying um misconstring uh
taking things out of context and you are
the reason why innocent men, women,
children, Muslims have been attacked all
over the world or even some of them
killed because of your rhetoric. This
man is saying America first. He's saying
why United States of Israel? It should
be United States. So America, he's
putting his country first. Let's carry
on and let's see how he catches shoots
himself in the foot again. Do you think
there's a blockade of any kind? So I
think they disengage in order to kill
the peace process. I think they put the
full blockade around the country for the
reason that they've always kind of done
it there that yeah, they don't want too
much stuff getting in. They want to keep
them as they put it on a diet and they
don't want uh rockets to fly into
Israel. If that desire to live in peace
beside your neighbors had superseded the
desire to stockpile rockets, it would
all be different. Yeah. Or them for 60
years, it would all be different, too.
It's always on them. The World Bank said
in 1996 for the one quoting the World
Bank. This doesn't mean anything. This
is a non-argument. Yes, I'm saying the
World Bank did their own analysis of
this and they said that it was a 40%.
Hold on. You got to stop interrupting
and let him finish the sentence. The
World Bank said that 40% drop in the GDP
of one year due to the blockade and
there's been a blockade from 2007 on.
So, are you saying that this hasn't had
an economic effect? Is that the
argument? No, of course it will have an
economic effect. So, you're saying you
have to be on the ground and do an audit
of the blockade in order to become I
think you should at least know what it
is, what the territory is, what the what
the situation is in the region. Yes,
absolutely. And the only way to do that
is to be there in person. I think that's
the best way. either take on the
arguments or don't. But I don't. Except
your argument is incorrect. Okay, fine.
Well, then then present a counter
argument to it. But just tell me I'm not
allowed to talk about an expert talk
about you haven't been there. Yeah, I
know. But you keep playing this game
where it's like the whole opening to
this podcast was like the non-experts
talking about this is such a problem.
Now you're saying I haven't been there.
I can't talk about it. Is there a
blockade there that's causing economic
devastation or not? World Bank there is.
I do believe that one of the things you
should do if you're talking about
something is to see it. Yeah, you is
there a blockade? The reason why uh
trucks get searched is not because the
Israelis want to search through grain or
flour. It's because they wanted to stop
the trucks containing the arms and to
understand it properly. Whenever you
gone to the Muslims and who've been
massacred, yes, we talk about they hate
the west. They don't hate the west. They
do not hate the west. They don't care
about you and your freedoms and your
degeneracy. You can keep it to yourself,
mate. Yes. Whenever you go to these
regions and spoke to Muslims and said,
"What's your problem with the west?" And
they will come and say, "You are
massacring us. You're coming to our
lands and stealing our resources." And
very interestingly when he shoots him in
the foot and they pulled him up on this
which is that he's like well if you come
and he's like oh if you uh you know if
they stop uh stop send rockets Hamas
then we will not be doing this. Hold on
a second. And they said well if you
haven't been occupying them for that
many years they wouldn't be doing what
they doing. And this is the next
reaction I'm going to show you is where
Douglas Murray shoots himself in the
foot by actually making an argument for
the Palestinians. Watch this for
yourself cuz I don't know how people
miss this out. Watch this carefully.
views about iron ore production in the
Bavarian forest and and this sort of
thing. And I remember everyone was all
over the place and the moderator turned
to the historian Andrew Roberts and
said, "Andrew Roberts, why did World War
II begin?" And he said, "World War II
began because Hitler invaded Poland."
And those moments come along quite often
at the moment, which is yes, there's an
awful lot of very interesting things to
look into. There's a lot of very
interesting things going on which we
should all be able to talk about and do
talk about but sometimes you have to
remember the origin causes of things as
well and you have to stick to keeping
that in mind. Yeah. And I think that a
lot of people are pretty bad at the
moment of keeping that in mind like you
can there you can concede Ukrainian
corruption you can concede uh all sorts
of things and still not lose sight of
the thing of if Russia rolls tanks into
neighboring countries it can't be
allowed. Oh, well, listen. Okay. So, on
that, I think we have an area of
agreement. And did you hear that? Why
did World War II began? Yes. He's
talking about somebody who's biging up
and saying, you know, the guy put all of
those little leaves to the side. Let's
go to the root of the problem. Why did
World War II start? Because Hitler went
into Poland. Why did the war start with
Russia? Because Russia brought his
tongue to his neighboring countries.
Okay. So, you're trying to make a point
based on the root of the problem is
what? That if they did not do that, if
Hitler didn't go to Poland to World War
II start, fair point. If Russia didn't
bring the tanks, which I don't know if
it's true or not, the neighboring
countries, the war with Ukraine wouldn't
start, you scumbag. And if Zionists did
not go and steal the lands from the
Palestinians, we would not be here, you
Do you understand? You just shot
yourself a shotgun on your head. Boom.
Intellectual. Have you realized? Do you
see? When they perpetually lie, they
don't even realize. They even make
counter arguments against theirelves.
You cannot make this up. You've just
made an argument for the Palestinians.
And that is the point of Dave Smith and
Joe Rogan. Salute to Joe Rogan. It kind
of hard to like lecture a group of
people who are going through so much
like the level of human suffering that's
being inflicted on the people of Gaza
right now cannot be overstated. And so,
you know, to lecture about how you're
supposed to handle that. Exactly. But I
will say, man, I think there's kind of
this selective empathy that you have
here. You know, I'm talking about
October 7th, but at the same time, we're
not having this conversation on October
9th or in November or December of 2023.
We're having it in 2025 where the the
tragedy that's been inflicted on Gaza is
orders of magnitudes greater than
October 7th. There are just every day
people are inundated with images of just
dead women and children. This is like
one of the most brutal wars. And by
several metrics that really, you know,
like personally matter to me, like the
number of dead kids, like that's a
pretty good one. It's more children have
died than in any recent war. I mean,
this is like it does I do think there's
almost um like a fundamental framing
bias. It seems to me that there's almost
an implicit difference in the value that
you place on Israeli life versus the
value that we place on Palestinians
life. And to even like we've gone this
far into the conversation and haven't
even talked about the fact that like
Israel has feel if you want to argue I
haven't been there. Stuff does get
through the blockade. Okay, fine. This
is a captive people. You know that
Israel has dominated since at least
1967. Many of them are there because of
the creation of the state of Israel who
used to live in what is now called
Israel and they are just I mean the
amount of human suffering that's being
inflicted on them when Hamas in many
ways was forced on these people. In
fact, we saw protest against Hamas just
recently. So I don't know. I mean that
to me seems to be the greatest human
tragedy and I think much more so than
you can characterize it as people being
pro Hamas or people being anti-Semitic.
I actually think that the mass movement
around the world of people who oppose
this war has been that people feel
really awful about all these babies.
Yeah. Clearly in that I wish there was a
reaction video to Dr. Murray's face. Not
remorse, no guilt, nothing. He's talking
about Dave Smith's talking about
massacring men, women, and children have
been massacred. The guy does not even
finish. He doesn't even condemn. He's
basically saying the price is worth it.
He's the the reason why he has a problem
with Joe Rogan and Dave Smith is because
he's saying the price is worth it
killing these innocent babies, children,
women that he's talking about. He talks
about women's rights, etc. with the
hijab. Okay, you scumbag, you double st
hypocrite. He's basically saying the
price is worth it. They should be killed
because the of the greater the picture.
That is the point here. That is the
point here. No remorse. What a vile
person once. And there he absolutely did
not downplay any of the Nazi atrocities
at all. And I would also I would I think
that if we're zooming out here a little
bit, maybe this is kind of part of the
disconnect broadly speaking in American
culture. The idea that it has not been
driven into people enough that the Nazis
were bad and that Adolf Hitler was a he
is literally the modern devil. He is
much more so than the actual devil.
Adolf Hitler is what's viewed as the
most evil thing to the point that I mean
just my entire life growing up if there
was a guy who sold soup on Seinfeld who
was like authoritarian. He's a soup
Nazi. Everyone was Hitler. The left
called George Bush Hitler and they
called Obama Hitler and they called
Trump Hitler. Every single enemy that
we've gone to war with in always called
Hitler, Saddam Hussein's the new Hitler,
Muhammad Gaddafi is the new Hitler,
Putin's the new Hitler. It is so so the
idea that like we haven't driven into
people enough. Adolf Hitler wasn't
really saying that at all. I'm not
saying that at all. I'm saying just as
the left likes to play with very dark
ugly stuff and they've done it for
decades. They have done they have played
down Chairman Ma's murder of the Chinese
throughout his era in power. They played
down Stalin. They still march on
occasions with posters of Lenin. They
they've spent decades trying to do down
evils that were done on their side. And
he's now having a go at some guy called
Daryl something whatever downplaying um
uh the anti-semitism of Hitler or
something like that. Yes. Uh he's making
that point. My friend, Hitler is the
thing they would use. The card that they
use Hitler and Holocaust is to carry out
these massacres. People have woken up.
It's not working anymore. There are
Jews, real Jews, who are coming and
design Jews who are coming and saying,
"You are not going to use this Holocaust
card to do another Holocaust. It's not
going to work. You're not going to do
it." And fairly so, they're speaking
out. They're just they're not experts.
And if there's anyone that could talk
about this, I mean, it's those who have
gone through the Holocaust. They're the
the grandchildren of those who went
through the Holocaust. They are saying
it's not going to work. And this guy is
here talking about that. And then
towards the end, he talks about those
who have downplayed what Lenon and
Maoang etc. You are downplaying what
Israel is doing. Does this guy hear
himself? I cannot. Guys, have you picked
up on this? Please let me know. I'm When
I pull my hair out, I haven't got any
hair left as you can see. Yeah, guys. He
is saying they're downplaying that. And
you are downplaying the atrocities of
Israel. Last reaction video. Comment
this guy. This guy absolutely
annihilated. I get stuff on Twitter. I
just do not want I do not want a guy
with one and a half thousand followers
who's got some zany new view on
something who isn't an expert but is an
expert to be pushed at me. And
effectively what is happening with the
Twitter algorithm is happening
everywhere else as well. And we're all
for the open marketplace of ideas. I
want that. I thrive in it. But it is it
is different once you get into the thing
of is something manipulating the
algorithm behind is the algorithm being
pushed on me. Why am I being given this?
Why am I not being given that? Why am I
being constantly pushed this view? And I
think that the answer to a goal lastly
very simple he he has issues with
algorithm and people who are not experts
and some guy with 10,000 followers is
talking about this. You've been doing
this for the past 10 20 years my friend
talking about Islam. You're not an
expert. Yes, you've been guys pushing
the algorithm lying manipulating taken
out of context misconstruing about
Islam. You're not an expert. You are not
an expert. So why have you been talking
about it? Why have you been talking
about Islam in such a way where you have
no idea? Have you come and sat with
Muslims? Spoken with Muslims understood
the Quran spoke to spoke to the people
in the region of do they hate the west?
They don't hate the west. They're like,
"Leave us alone. Leave us alone." That
is the thing. And I want to salute Joe
Rogan. Hats off to you. Hats off to you.
I know. Sorry. That's But hats off to
you, brother sisters. Joe Rogan is
waking up. The whole entire world is
waking up. It is the beginning of the
end of Zionism and Israel. And I hope we
live to see it.
Weber.